Her low freak bitches. See I, I,
there's Tyron Woodley thing is very tricky
because in my mind like I see that he
wanted to win the fight period.
That is the best way to win the fight.
If this guy was only offering a certain
amount of offense and you could stuff
that offense and land your shots
and continue to pile up points,
which he did and don't ever
put yourself at risk, I get it.
But I also get the Dana white
point of view where he's like,
you've got to sell tickets.
Like people are paying to see you fight
and if people are holding up cell phones
and swinging them through the rafters,
you know,
because everybody's bored cause they
don't want to watch it anymore. And his,
his thought is like,
you've got to sell tickets.
And who's the greatest take
down artists in UFC history?
George Saint Pierre Towards
San Pio versus Woodley. Yeah,
but Woodley apparently,
um,
because of this fight they're
talking about GSP versus Bisping now.
Oh they got to go to woodland.
Come on. That's the only guy.
If GSP just take Woodley down,
nobody can.
But what if they just tried
to take each other down,
back and forth and everybody went crazy
again. Kim Down repeatedly. If he did,
he'd, that'd be great too. But what if he
did? Either way, I want to see the fight.
Here's the cause,
the cause Woodley has a style.
Some people don't like it.
Some people like it,
some people appreciate it or whatever.
But the only guy that has
a shot to beat Woodley,
the only guy would be the best takedown,
best MMA takedown artist of all time.
He has like a million
takedowns in the UFC.
He's the only guy that would be able
to, if GSP can do it, no one can.
He's going to have to just
like, yeah, very good striker.
I think he's leg kicks.
This is what you'd have GSP saying.
Like we've got to go to the
pro wrestling angle. You know,
I have tired of sitting at
home watching boring fights.
That's bad GSP impression. I bit
him saying like, enough identity.
I want my sound like Arnold.
Kenny made it here. Some Ivs.
Um, I don't know. Bisping's
I want any five. That's kind
of weird. Is he saying, man,
it's going to be too hard to
make one 70 without the ivs?
I think he was willing
to fight either fight.
I think he was willing to do one 70
or one AVT Woodley. GSP would be huge.
That would, that would be the biggest
fight for what I'm not impressed with
because who else is there at
one seven eight that could they,
it has a chance of taking him down.
Well, Robbie Lawler, since he just won,
you would have to look at Robbie being
one of the top contenders and he would
just brawl with him.
He's willing to brawl with and that's
the only way you're gonna beat him if he
can avoid the big bomb that he got hit
with in the first five. Yeah. You know,
and you've got to think,
Robbie Lawler is coming off of
five round war with Rory Macdonald,
five round war with Carlos Condit,
war with Johny Hendricks,
war war, war, war. It's
all war. Every fight.
He's in his fucking war.
So like, I think the,
him having that year off was giant.
And then he fought cowboy.
And towards the end he
was coming after cowboy.
He was hurting cowboy to the body.
He hit Cabo with some big shots.
I felt like a lot of people
disagree with that decision,
but I felt like I give Robbie the first
round because he jumped all over cowboy
in the beginning and was,
I think it was enough to win the round.
Although I think Cabo is getting the
better of the exchanges towards the NSL
silting the volume of it and the impact
went to Robbie second round went cowboy
pretty big.
But then Robbie rallied in the third
round and I think he dominated the third
round and I think he
hurt cowboy a few times.
I think that would have been
an amazing five round fight.
That would have been an incredibly even
remember who won the fight. Robbie?
One very close decision. I think
it was a split decision. I don't,
I'm not sure that my grade five brain
is scrambled. It was a great fight.
It was a great fight. Both gave, both
took. It was, it was war. It was chaos,
you know, and in Cowboy, um, definitely
caught him with some clean shots.
He hit him with some real good knees.
The body as well.
Cowboy landed a lot of great shit, but
you know, Robbie looked like Robbie again.
He looked like the Robbie Lawler that
won the title. It looks like a killer.
He looked like the same spooky dude that
just keeps coming after you until he
puts you away. That's what he
looked like in the third round.
Third round in particular.
Really looked like it was falling back
into the old groove again. So there's him,
you know?
Yeah.